AND TALKING ABOUT EVERYTHING.
BEFORE HE WAS INDEED.
WHILE THAT IS HAPPENING, WE HAVE
A FOX NEWS ALERT FOR YOU.
DALE EARNHARDT JR. HAS BEEN
HOSPITALIZED, FOLLOWING A PLANE
CRASH.
>> DANA, WE CAN CONFIRM THAT
DALE EARNHARDT JR. WAS WITH HIS
WIFE AND ANOTHER PASSENGER ALONG
WITH TWO PILOTS.
A 10 FEET TWIN ENGINE TRAIN
CRASHED IN EASTERN TENNESSEE.
THAT'S IN BRISTOL, TENNESSEE.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE AREA, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT HALFWAY
BETWEEN CHARLOTTE AND KNOXVILLE.
THE PLANE, BY THE WAY, IF YOU
SEE THE PICTURES OF THE SMOKE,
THE PLANE HAD ABOUT A THOUSAND
GALLONS OF FUEL ON BOARD.
AUTHORITIES SAY A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THAT LEAK.
YOU CAN SEE THAT FROM THE FIRE.
THE STATUS THAT LOOKS, WE ARE
BEING TOLD RIGHT NOW THAT DALE
EARNHARDT JR., HIS WIFE AND
YOUNG DAUGHTER AND ALL THE
PASSENGERS SUFFERED ONLY MINOR
INJURIES.
THERE WAS SOME VIDEO SHOWING
DALE EARNHARDT JR..
THEY WERE PUTTING A NECK BRACE
AROUND HIS NECK.
IT APPEARED THAT HE WAS LIFTING
HIS HEAD ON HIS OWN.
HIS SISTER, ALSO HIS BUSINESS
PARTNER, KELLY EARNHARDT TWEETED
THE FOLLOWING.
"I CAN CONFIRM THAT THEY WERE
INVOLVED IN A CRASH IN BRISTOL,
TENNESSEE.
EVERYONE IS SAFE AND HAS BEEN
TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL FOR
FURTHER EVALUATION.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER INFORMATION
AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR UNDERSTANDING."
>> WE DO NOT KNOW THE SEVERITY
OF THE INJURIES, BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT EVERYONE WHO WAS ON THE
PLANE GOT OFF THE PLANE.
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW, OF COURSE,
DALE EARNHARDT JR., 18 YEAR
CAREER, 12 DAYTONA 500'S.
HE WENT ON TO WIN.
40TH OF ALL TIME IN NASCAR.
THE REASON HE WAS FLYING TO
BRISTOL.
WITH HIS WIFE AND HIS 1-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER.
THE LATEST REPORTS ARE THAT THEY
ALL GOT OFF THE PLANE AND THERE
ARE ONLY MINOR INJURIES.
WHEN YOU SEE THE SMOKE LIKE
THAT, AND IF YOU SAW OTHER
PICTURES OF THE PLANE ITSELF,
WHICH CAME IN AND ROLLED OFF THE
END OF THE RUNWAY, YOU WOULD BE
SURPRISED THAT ANYBODY WALKED
AWAY FROM THAT.
WE'LL HAVE MUCH MORE BREAKING
INFORMATION ON THE CRASH OF DALE
EARNHARDT JR.'S PLANE.
REMEMBER, HIS FATHER DIED IN A